welcome to cloud security basics a
series where we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application on google
cloud
sound fun then stick around because in
this episode you'll learn
good practices for securing your
application with cloud i am
[Music]
it's been a while cloud detective i see
you understand the flexibility and
capabilities of the cloud
as you know it makes it easier to work
faster and collaborate more effectively
but it also introduces new
responsibilities and security risks
and sometimes those threats are not on
the outside
accounts can get hacked credentials
leaked and employees
disgruntled whether accidental or
willful
internal users represent the biggest
threat to your organization's cloud
security
for your sake detective i hope you can
keep the wrong people
from accessing the wrong resources at
the wrong time
okay here's what we know companies
need to make sure that only the right
people can access only the right
resources
at only the right time one way to keep
bad actors out would be to cut
access for everyone and have a few
trusted people dole out access manually
but keeping productivity high and
getting the most out of your cloud
platform depends on employees
having access to the resources and
assets they need
with the least amount of friction or
delay and while just manually allowing
access
every time a person or application needs
resources
might work for a very very small
organization
that would quickly grow unwieldy as the
teams grow or begin to work remotely
so in order for our organization to grow
and function
we need a better way to manage access
luckily
google cloud provides a lot of tools and
services to protect its users
and this seems like a good time to use
google cloud's identity and access
management
actually so im is google cloud's unified
system for managing resource
access assigning user permissions and
controlling cloud application service
use
it unifies all access and control and
centralizes it
into one place resources are the
fundamental
lowest level components that make up all
google cloud services
so some examples would include compute
engine vms
pub sub topics cloud storage buckets and
app engine instances cloud im lets
organizations keep track of
everything going on in their google
cloud environment and prevent
unauthorized resource access let's
research more to know how i can use this
to stop those threats
cloud im's access management system
breaks down into a few basic parts
there's members resources permissions
roles policies and groups
members or identities can be a google
account
for end users a service account used to
manage
apps and virtual machines a google group
or a google workspace
cloud identity domain able to access a
resource
the member's identity is usually the
associated email address
service account or group or domain name
resources these are the fundamental
components that make up all google cloud
services like vms
storage buckets and more the
organizations
folders and projects used to organize
them are also considered resources
and permissions which are very
fine-grained access control on a
particular resource
roles a role is a collection of
permissions and permissions determine
what operations are allowed on a
resource
when you grant a role to a member you
grant them all the permissions the role
contains
google cloud has predefined built-in
roles and you can also create
custom roles policies which bind a set
of cloud
im members to a role and if you want to
define
who has what type of access on a
resource you create a policy and attach
it to
that resource the policy also has other
information
such as auditing configuration but we're
going to focus on identity aspects for
now
and groups groups are used to help you
manage users at scale
each member of a google group inherits
the identity and access management roles
that you granted
to that group and this means that you
can use a group's membership
to manage users roles instead of
granting
i am roles to individual users
so how should i use i am to protect my
organization from
inside threats i could start by using
groups from the beginning
this way the security admin wouldn't
have to manually change permissions as
employees get
hired fired or moved throughout the
organization
because the right policies would be
assigned to anyone i move
into the correct group this would also
make it a lot easier to minimize
mistakes
because instead of assigning roles and
permissions to a specific employee
we could assign them to groups and then
add employees to the correct groups
this works even if you already have an
organizational hierarchy
and groups in an existing system like
active directory
and in that case you can continuously
sync that configuration to cloud i am
providing a single source of truth for
group membership
and reducing the chance of a mistake and
once we have groups
we could also make sure to name the
groups descriptively
so that it's obvious to tell at a glance
what each of the roles has access to
and this should significantly reduce
mistakes that come from assigning the
wrong roles to the wrong groups
a good strategy here would be to make a
nested folder hierarchy apparent with
naming
one general rule would be to begin with
the organization
name and then expand out the folder tree
with the project name
that's it i can use these components to
shore up my system's defenses
let's see what brad actor thinks about
that ah
detective it seems like you've foiled my
attempt again
somehow you figured out that properly
using cloud iam
greatly reduces the risk of security
violations
i'm surprised you even picked up on
using groups to simplify the process of
managing access rights
for employees that move around your
organization
but what about the access you've given
to non-human entities like
applications that need to access your
secure resources to function
have you secured those for your sake
i hope you have because next time i'm
not focusing on your employees
but instead on your scripts and
applications
so there you have it another episode of
cloud security basics
next episode we'll focus on using
service accounts to protect
automated access to your cloud resources
so stay tuned for the rest of the cloud
security basics series
because when it comes to security you
can't let bad actors win
you